a fantastic move i mean what a resource  he just took a pawn and the whole point  is that  this  the knight is forced to stay on its  square otherwise the queen will drop  back and give a check and look at magnus  there he knows on his body language he  knows he's losing uh just everything is  hanging for black the black bishop is  under fire the black knight is loose the  black rook as well very very vulnerable  and okay he moves his rook away but now  rook trade and black is running out of  pieces i don't think black's got many  moves available to him whatever black  plays um might lose material um  could be getting near the end of the  match wow  the results there we go  it's over  liam  wins the match against world champion  magnus carlsen on a bad day for magnus  what a great day for liam le winning two  games here  and we're going to follow them out to  the